évidemment comme dans tous les discours
ya des choses avec lesquelles je me
retrouve moins en phase
d'abord on ne sait pas beaucoup de
choses en plus de certaines mesures dans
les modalités pourrait être sujette à
problèmes on a entendu qu'il y avait une
réforme des institutions la dose de
proportionnelle par exemple je peux
entendre qu'il en faut une mais en
fonction de la dose je suis bon je suis
content parce qu'on bascule dans insiste
la représentation de tous les courants
et de toutes les familles politiques oui
une assemblée ingouvernable pour faire
en sorte qu'elles puissent pas se
réformer non de la même manière quand
j'entends évoqué la question de la
suppression de la baisse de la taxe
d'habitation
je suis interrogatif notamment parce
qu'on sait bien que c'est une ressource
essentielle des collectivités locales
ça veut dire quoi
ça va être remplacé par quoi avec quel
dynamisme quand on ne le dit il va
falloir engager une institution qui est
plus de concertation avec les
collectivités de calmer tout devra faire
des efforts on parle de quel montant
tout ça s'il vous plaît pour moi ce sont
autant de questions sur lesquelles je
veux m'efforcer de rester dans une forme
de bienveillance
mais j'ai de vraies inquiétudes à la
fois parce qu'il ne sort pas aujourd'hui
d'une ambiguïté sur ce que sera la
portée ou la nature de ces mesures
et parce que dans le même temps on a
maintenant on aura nous aussi dans
quelques semaines dans quelques mois a
commencé à construire des budgets à
faire des plans pluriannuels
d'investissements et donc à avoir la
nécessité pouvoir se projeter le
rétablissement d'un service national
j'en comprends la porte et je suis
sceptique la fois sur le coup sûr les
mesures qu'on envisage et sur le fait de
savoir s'il est seulement nationale la
manière donc
on aurait pu au contraire associés
peut-être davantage des collectivités
locales sur les activités périscolaires
qui sont des vraies questions
vous avez des dizaines et des dizaines
de d'employés dans vos services qui
travaillent sur ces sujets on n'en sait
pas beaucoup plus donc la réforme du bac
en 2021 très bien mais il se passe quoi
à la rentrée 2010 8